[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace conosur desde
uruguay en el programa del día de hoy
hablaremos como la inflación incide en
el país la más alta desde diciembre del
2020 también conoceremos cómo los
exportadores uruguayos se han visto
afectados por la guerra en ucrania al no
poder enviar ni cobrar los productos que
venden a rusia
[Música]
la inflación es un tema que agobia a
muchos países del mundo en estos
momentos y uruguay no es la excepción
según recientes encuestas y opinión
pública el poder adquisitivo es el tema
que más preocupa a los uruguayos hoy en
día el último año la inflación volvió a
registrar aumentos el índice de precios
al consumo en los 12 meses cerrados en
marzo se situó en 9 con 4% los productos
que más registraron alza fueron los
alimentos y bebidas no alcohólicas con
un 12 con 4 por ciento en marzo la
inflación en uruguay registró un aumento
sostenido durante los últimos 5 años en
gran medida influenciada por los precios
de los commodities a nivel internacional
y desde diciembre del 2020 el aumento es
mayor fruto de la crisis sanitaria que
recientemente de la guerra y lucran ya
se está notando el aumento en general
sobre todo en alimentos lo de no
adquisitivo el problema del trabajo hay
escasez pero bueno está hay que hacer de
todo un poco
además de los alimentos el precio de los
combustibles se ha transformado en el
tema diario de conversación entre la
población la nafta aumentó un 2% y el
caso hay un 1 con 98 por ciento era todo
menos afectado totalmente porque
imagínate que en un poco tiempo que haya
subido el canal de beagle hoy en día el
per y menta ca-181 pesos increíble el
precio de la gasolina es un digamos un
insumo y que debería de estar en todas
las canastas básicas no ante un contexto
internacional con un alza importante en
el precio de las materias primas y una
suma de los combustibles el gobierno
uruguayo tomó varias medidas para
mitigar el impacto e intentar frenar la
inflación el gobierno ha decidido
agregar al aumento llegado a principio
de año
un 3% a las jubilaciones y a las
pensiones
y agregar al aumento al público llamado
principio año un
2%
estas medidas de coyuntura por supuesto
lo que tratan de hacer es buscar las
mejores herramientas
posibles y las más efectivas para no
poder para no perder poder
adquisitivo mientras tanto varios
economistas ven las medidas del gobierno
como cortoplacistas y contradictorias
con las políticas que venía
implementando el banco central
muchas de esas medidas rebajas de iva
transitorias bueno también las la
contención de los precios de algunas
tarifas en particular de los
combustibles no reflejando en su
totalidad lo que ha sido la suba del
petróleo
de alguna manera intentan comprar tiempo
digamos a pagar un poco el incendio más
inmediato estamos muy cerca del 10 por
ciento de inflación y es el uruguay es
un umbral psicológico
bastante bastante importante y bueno y
en ese marco es que deben entenderse
como como elementos que intentan moderar
las presiones más intensas más de corto
plazo no van a ser eficaces para
contener de manera
significativa y de manera duradera lo
que son las presiones inflacionarias en
lo que también coinciden varios
economistas es el que la recuperación
salarial que permitirá restaurar el
poder adquisitivo de la población
no se logrará al menos hasta el 2023
además de la inflación otros problemas
están también presionando la economía
uruguaya como lo es la guerra en ucrania
varias exportaciones se vieron afectadas
y el sector agrícola también sufrió un
gran impacto con la suba de los precios
de las semillas y los fertilizantes del
país del norte de asia
el principal rubro que exporta uruguay a
rusia son los lácteos con cerca de 70
millones que se obtienen de la venta
siendo la manteca el producto estrella
otros productos que se venden a rusia
son caviar carne soja productos
derivados de la pesca frutas vinos
medicamentos y subproductos de la lana
nosotros exportamos
a ucrania ya rusia más a rusia que
ucrania
productos que tienen que ver con la
cadena alimenticia estos productos
algunos nos agarraron el evento en el
mar
llegando a los puertos tuvimos que
desviar los a otros puertos también
sucedió que otros puertos no recibían
nuestra mercadería los exportadores
uruguayos también debieron sortear
dificultades para poder cobrar los
productos que ya habían sido colocados
en rúsia esto tras las sanciones
internacionales a los pagos
internacionales conocidos por sus siglas
en inglés swift entretanto el sector
agrícola también vivió momentos de
incertidumbre cuando por ejemplo los
fertilizantes duplicaron su valor
mermando así sus márgenes de ganancia de
este modo llegamos al cierre de este
enlace conosur desde uruguay continúe
con nosotros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]